تحديدا بالقرب من الحدود بين
الكوريتين كتحذير خطير بشأن
لها. كبير مستشاري خامنئي يدعو
لفتح السفارتين الايرانية
من المساعدات العسكرية الامريكية
لمصر دقت طبول المعركة وتهيأت
هيئة الاركان العامة للجيش
الشعبي الكوري ويدعو الى الوقف
تقديم مساعدات مالية لاوكرانيا
بقيمة اربعمائة مليون دولار لا
طلقاته المدفعية كهدية تحذيرية
لجيرانه. ليخرج المتحدث باسم
العسكرية في شبه الجزيرة. فهل
يستجيب الجيران لذلك؟ الاحداث
السبب فكيف ستواجه ذلك. دهاء
بكين. اصحاب العيون الضيقة
عشر ماليزيا على الاقل بعد تعقب
نشطاء فلسطينيين في البلاد.
انقرة نفت ذلك داعية نتنة الى
وضع حد لاتهاماتها التي لا اساس
الملكي البريطاني لتدريب قواتها
على كيفية اسقاط الطائرات
التدريبات العسكرية التي تجريها
كوريا الجنوبية. نعم. كم يقدم
من تحرير الرهينة خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعة. منع عضو ديمقراطي
والسعودية ويقول نحن جيران ويجب
ان نتعايش. ماليزيا تعلن عن
تعلن عن نفسها يا سادة. في
الاراضي اليونانية. عشرات
الخلية اختطفت خبيرا فلسطينيا في
تكنولوجيا المعلومات حتى يخضع
كبير في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
خمسة وسبعين مليون دولار اضافي
امريكية تفيد بان الصين استخدمت
طيارين سابقين في سلاح الجو
المجنون. لا تمر الايام على
كوريا الشمالية كما تمر في باقي
استدراج طيارين ومحاولة
اغرائهما. تقارير استخباراتية
الغربية وهو ما دفع جنرالا سابقا
في الجيش الى وصفهم بالخونة وذلك
الاحتياطي يا بايدن. البيت
الابيض يصرح. اعلان السعودية عن
عسكري مشترك. المعركة الكبرى.
معركة دق الرؤوس وطحن العظام.
اليونان وتركيا. فمن فعل بهم
هذا? هدايا جديدة من كوريا
الهادئ ولسان حاله يقول القاذفات
النووية ان كنا مفلسين ليأتي هنا
الى الامريكان. نعم الرئيس بايدن
يقرر سحب خمسة عشر مليون برميل
وهو اشبه بمسلسل ناروتو. تسع
وتسعون حلقة يتخيل ماضيه. وفي
هنا يطلق قرابة مائتين وخمسين
طلقة مدفعية على المناطق العازلة
من هذا الاحتياطي بحسب تصريح
مسؤول امريكي. بايدن يحاول تجنب
الحلقة المائة يسقط مغشيا عليه.
يا لهذه الحرب الخجولة. هدايا
تستمر الصين بخرق الاجواء. لقد
اصبح مسلسل تايوان والصين مملا
تستمر اربعة ايام في البحر
الابيض المتوسط لتنفيذ تمرين
والتفاوض مع اوكرانيا لتبديد
الاتهامات متعلقة بتزويد روسيا
الفوري للاستفزازات المتهورة
والتحريضية والتي اثارت التوترات
المثل العربي اخف بالموت ليرضى
بالحمى. هنا وزيرة الخارجية
يحاربون على عديد الجبهات. لكنهم
يسلكون اقصر الطرق وكل الطرق
نعم حرب المناورات. الرد الروسي
جاء سريعا لتعلن عن تأهبها
الالماس واليورانيوم التي لا
عقوبات عليها لتقف حجر عثرة امام
بحسب صحيفة ديلي ميل. وفي الجبهة
المقابلة. الدفاعات التيوانية
اضافي الاحتياطي النفطي الامريكي
ولا يستبعد بايدن استخدام المزيد
كانت معارضة للحرب الاوكرانية.
واضافت اننا مستعدون للحوار
وزيرة خارجيتها فياله من رد
ماكر. ومن حرب الاستخبارات الى
تعلن عن تعقب احد مقاتلة جوية
وسفينتين حربيتين صينيتين بمنطقة
وعسكريا. رد بوتين جاء في عملية
نشر قاذفات نووية فوق المحيط
وزارة الداخلية الالمانية اقالة
رئيس المكتب الاتحادي لامن
خطيرة وستعمل على اطلاق صواريخ
نووية خلال تدريبات جروم السنوي.
تؤدي الى بكين هذه المرة. وبعد
ان اعلنت بريطانيا استيائها من
بمسيرات. ليخرج وزير الخارجية
الاوكراني بتصريح صادم بقوله
في كييف بحسب صحيفة بيلد
الالمانية وقد يرجح انها تهديدات
تحقيق اهداف الدول الاوروبية.
لكن ها هي العقوبات يصل ضررها
دعم روسيا بطائرات مسيرة هنا
الخارجية الايرانية تصرح انها
المضيق لتستمر تايوان بمراقبة كل
تحركات الصين وسكناتها بينما
روسيا لا طائل منها بسبب وجود ما
وصفته بالابقار المقدسة وهي
هذا الذي يجري? موسكو ترد على
مناورات الناتو النووية بقوة.
ترى? ومن المناورات النووية الى
المناورات الكلامية. وبعد ان نفت
غضب الشارع الامريكي بتخفيض
الاسعار لكن ماذا ان لم يكفي
مواجهة العقوبات. نشرت نيويورك
تايمز ان العقوبات الغربية على
الدول. فالزعيم كيم جونغ لا يحب
الملل ويشعل الاجواء على الدوام.
الروسية بوتين ينفذ اختراقا ذكي
للاستخبارات الالمانية ردا على
الالمانية انالينا بربوك برلين
ستدعم اوكرانيا مجددا. وفي مقدمة
للسيطرة على محطة زابروتش
النووية الحرب على اشدها يا
بانتظار معركة طاحنة يا اصدقاء.
بوتين يستعرض معظم اوراقه
قرار منظمة اوبك بلس بخفض انتاج
النفط. واشنطن ترى ان الرياض هي
ستارت الجديدة والتي تلزمها
بذلك. فما الذي يخطط له الروس يا
هذه التجهيزات الحربية لتخرج
السلطات الروسية وتعلن اخلاء
روسيا طائرات ايرانية مسيرة يفضح
موسكو ويؤكد انها مفلسة سياسيا
الدعم ستكون الدفاعات الجوية
متجاهلة تحذيرات موسكو لتعلن
تكنولوجيا المعلومات وذلك بسبب
وجود علاقات تربطه بالاستخبارات
متر باتجاه خرسون فكيف ستكون هذه
المعركة الحاسمة? يجيب الرئيس
لتدريبات خلال الايام القادمة.
لكن المفاجئ هنا هو ان موسكو لم
تخطر واشنطن بالامر حسب
الاتفاقات والبروتوكولات الدولية
ايران حقيرة ومخادعة. بينما وجه
كلماته نحو الروس بقوله استخدام
المقررة في العشرين من اكتوبر
الجاري بسبب التداعيات الامنية
سفينة العاصفة والمسلحة بصواريخ
كاليبر المجنحة. فهل حان وقت
المناورات البحرية المشتركة
الفين واثنين وعشرين. الجزائر
ليصرح مسؤول امريكي رفيع المستوى
بان روسيا تستعد لاجراء تجارب
الحرب البحرية؟ خلال ذلك اعلنت
موسكو احباط محاولة اوكرانية
وبوتين يخرج سفينته العاصفة.
وامريكا تصرخ. عقوبات الغرب لا
تجاهل موسكو ابلاغ واشنطن بهذه
الخطوة النووية يمثل لمعاهدة
امنية من جهة الروس. ومن الحرب
الضروس الى الاستعراض النووي.
الرادعة وبعد طايرة وغواصة يوم
القيامة ها هو الرئيس يختبر
تركيا يا لقساوة هذه المناظر!
اثنت تامة تركيا بهذا الجرم لكن
ومساعدات السعودية لا تشفع لها
لدى واشنطن. وخيانة بريطانية
سادة. ليتراجع الرئيس الالماني
عن قراره ويلغي زيارته لاوكرانيا
لتحقيقات ضباط اسرائيليين عبر
الفيديو قبل ان تتمكن المخابرات
وزارة الدفاع الجزائرية تعلن عن
انطلاق مناورات مشتركة مع روسيا
وذلك بعد ان اعلن سابقا عن تطبيق
الاحكام العرفية للحرب نحن
سنقاتل حتى الموت في خرسون بينما
تشير التقارير الاعلامية الى ان
فسيتحدث عنها العالم بلا يا الهي
ما هذه الحشود العسكرية وما كل
تفكيك شبكة تجسس تابعة للموساد
الاسرائيلي مكونة من قوامها احد
اللاجئين يظهرون عراة وعليهم
اثار التعذيب على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا تهاجم من محورين وقد
حققت تقدما بعمق الى ثلاثين كيلو
الاجواء. فمن يظفر بمقاطعة خرسون
يا ترى?
في خرسون. واشار سروفيكن الى ان
كييف تحشد احتياطاتها على خط
عاجلا بانشاء مقرات للدفاع
الاقليمي في الاقاليم الاربعة
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بالفعل
وليس بالقول حيث اصدر قرارا
خرسون بعد انباء عن هجوم
اوكراني. القوات الروسية تصرح.
استنفار للجنود واجلاء للسكان.
انها معركة بوتين الكبرى. فما
غير العادة الجنرال سيرجي
سيروفيكين يقر بالتعرض لوضع حرج
تقليل وقوع ضحايا من المدنيين.
اما ضحايا القوات العسكرية
الوضع متوتر وخارج عن السيطرة
والاطراف مقبلة على المعركة
المساعدات على مصر بسبب روسيا
والجزائر وروسيا تعلنان عن عمل
المواجهة واكد ان موسكو لا تسعى
لتقدم سريع في اوكرانيا بل تحاول
استراليا ماليزيا تقف في وجه
الاسرائيلي وواشنطن توقف
يملأها الغضب في معركة قد تكون
هي لجيش بوتين في اوكرانيا. وعلى
الشمالية توزعها على الجيران. يا
لقلبك الكبير يا كيم. وبعد
تساعد الصين في كشف اسلحة الغرب.
عشرات اللاجئين عراة في حدود
الاستخبارات الالمانية والرئيس
الالماني يوقف رحلته الى كييف.
تؤثر على روسيا. والسبب الابقار
المقدسة. والكرملين يخترق